this is a production of Cornell
University
today about diversity between species
and I'm gonna might echo some of the
points that are pointed AVI made earlier
today was to finding that things were
not working exactly the same in a rabid
Optus or perhaps not as well in a rabid
opposites as they did in tomato hinting
that perhaps different species do things
a little bit differently and so this
this sub subtext of this talk is going
to be sort of whatever you thought was
happening in one system may or may not
be happening in something else so I'll
be talking specifically about obsessions
so I need to define that first and
that's the process of releasing parts
from the parent plant thanks falling off
so worried yeah
so you're most familiar with this in the
autumn leaves fall off fall off trees
and petals of size the spring of course
dandelion fruits of size pretty much all
the time including when you don't want
them to and the most famous story of a
position may be the Apple falling off
the tree onto Isaac Newton so in general
the location obsession is not random
it's not simple breaking obsession
occurs at a very specific position the
obsession zone sorry the obsession zone
which is here from a diagram of the
attrition zone in at the base of a leaf
where it attaches to the stem it's this
little line of very small cells and it
can form at different positions in
different plants so it can be the base
of the leaf the base of the pebbles
below the fruit below the seed so it's a
so it's something that happens in a lot
of parts of the plant today I'm going to
be focusing particularly on obsession
below the fruit
the most familiar obsession zones
are in the domesticated cereals so you
you know this if you've studied
domestication at all in the cereal crops
such as rice and wheat and all the
grasses obsession is set shedding of
seeds is called shattering so this one
this wild wheat on the Left shatters as
it breaks up there's a position in very
specific parts of the inflorescence
where as the process of domestication is
a loss of shattering which was selected
unconsciously by humans
notice if you're going out and selecting
as this guy is here harvesting with a
scythe and then as these women are doing
here wrapping the the stalks into shoes
obviously what you're doing is you're
selecting for plants in which there's no
obsession that as the seeds are on the
plant any seeds that are falling off end
up in the mud and you don't collect them
and so you're automatically selecting
for the loss of shattering it probably
took quite a while for this set of
mutations to get fixed but basically
what it means is that all the
domesticated cereals are natural mutants
in which shattering is lost so mutations
that disable the obsession zone and a
lot of what we know about obsession
zones come from these wild domesticated
comparisons and I'll be referring to a
number of these through the talk the
other reason why this is important is
that there's a lot of focus on improving
novel crops that also need to be
selected to reduce or completely
eliminate chattering so that I've just
put two here that we're working on right
now I'm not going to be talking about
this work in this talk particularly but
funny owns a species of digit area which
is edible but and as he's grown as a
crop in some parts of Africa death
is probably more widely cultivated both
of those drop their seeds although
toughest sort of holds on to them a
little better than phony and does so
that if you're selecting for yield in
these crops if you want to do that to
improve them you've got to reduce
shattering first because otherwise if
you lose lose the seeds then it doesn't
matter how wonderfully nutritious or
large that seed is it's just sitting
there in the mud and you're not going to
get it so it's an it's important a
target for selection and crop
improvement just a little bit of
introduction to the grass family I know
it's familiar to many of you here but
just to remind you it is a large plant
family it's about 12,000 species so
about 700 more than 700 genrih then I've
just put four of them across across the
bottom of course the big three are like
rice wheat and maize sorghum and millet
here and I need to introduce you to just
a little bit of grass floral and add me
not much but some the grass flowers are
arranged in little spikes so these
little structures known as spikelets so
this is a spike layer right here and
there it's a series of bracts
surrounding a fairly conventional flower
and the motor brats subtend the spikes
other two outer brats and then one
flower to flowers three flower 4 and so
forth these outer Brax
know are known as the glooms which is of
course you know when people study
grasses they get depressed about it and
it's people call it the gloomy flurry
but so to glooms person attending the
spikelet and that's that's the bit of
morphology i'll need to refer to for
this talk so here's another picture this
is switchgrass
there's first gloom second gloom and
then the flowers are above that so the
gloom sort of demarcate the bottom of
the spikelet in rice the obsessions own
forms above the gloom so the glooms are
these tiny little structures here the
red dotted line marks the obsession zone
and then when the spikelet breaks one
obsession encourage the glooms stay on
the plant these two little flaps and
then the rest of the flower in the seat
and everything falls off so you can show
that in this little diagram were made
the glooms in blue and the obsession
stone is red and their couple in rice a
couple of sterile flowers and the big
fertile flowers shown as this big green
egg like thing if you look at something
like bracket podium there's also a
position above the glooms so there's the
glooms at the bottom these little blue
things here and then you've got the
multiple flowers in bracket podium and
there's an opposition so in forms
between each set of flowers but still
above the glooms if we look at something
like millet or panicum like switchgrass
on the other hand the position is below
the gloom so there is a gloom and the
thing breaks off the spikelet falls off
entire so there's nothing there no brats
left on the plant so you've got a couple
of blooms here and then in a position
zone right below it so in some things
that I've just showed you got a sick
obsession above the glooms and some it's
the glooms so how does that sort out
across the grass family well in Qing you
who's a postdoc in my lab just
characterized a whole bunch of grasses
based on stuff from the literature of
her own observations and then mapped the
position of the obsession zone onto the
grass phylogeny and so blue is the
obsession above the glooms that's like
rice and braca podium which I just
showed you this race here's Brad podium
and that seems to be the ancestral
condition and then these things were
there's obsession below the glooms like
seat area is shown here in green and
that's a derived condition
and then there are a few things that
you're familiar with like tastes taste
dente or wheat in which there's a
position actually in the stalk of the
plant that's shown here I'm red but for
most of it I'm going to be talking about
today we're just looking at this this
simple transition simple transition
between below the glooms and above the
glooms
so that's the ancestral condition there
so then this raises a really obvious
question from the point of view of
genetics and development and the
question is is there just a single
obsession so module the the plant sort
of just moves it around depending on
where you know where it's it's gonna
form it's a single gen module conserved
and then the transcription factor or
something that sort of says oh I'll put
it here or put it there then this would
be expected this would be a you know one
one possible explanation of the
evolution so this is the question I'm
gonna be talking about today first
starting with simply histology that is
cutting sections right through the
positions of them and see what it looks
like moving on to QTL studies in
genome-wide Association studies and to
our NAC
trying to address this relatively
straightforward question so let's start
with it astrology most of what we know
comes from rice there's been a lot of
work on obsession that is shattering
interest mm-hmm comparing cultivated
rice with its wild shattering relatives
and survey in Asia the wild rice which
shatters is a real problem in
agriculture because obviously then it's
dropping seeds to produce weeds and get
in the field and compete with a crop so
if we take a vertical section right down
through through here so a longitudinal
section we just slice it down through
and stain it what you get is something
that looks like this and this is we've
done this in my lab these these so these
pictures are from my lab with their
pictures in the literature that are very
very similar
so the obsession zone the place where
things actually break is this little
line of cells right here and this I need
to introduce you to a few histological
stains so you know what the colors mean
so this is stained with saffron and oh
and fast green and San Fernando stains
both lignin
suberin so the pink indicates Lichtman
lignin and then the obsession zone
itself is not lignified so this is the
obsession zone here both sides and this
is a vascular strand going down
connecting the the bottom of the
spikelet down to the rest of the stock
so lignin and no lignin this is another
staying floor boost in all HCl which is
much more specific for just lignin you
get basically the same pattern that the
place where it actually breaks is this
zone of small thin walled cells so
that's fine it's kind of intuitive I
just think you have trouble seeing it
I've just drawn a squiggly little line
and the squiggles mean nothing other
than the fact that I can't draw very
well on a mousepad and people have
looked at this this is a one paper from
the literature looking at the African
rice compared to a mutant
here's obviously we've now got acridine
orange which is also still standing
lignin it's just now green there's the
obsession zone and in one of the non
chattering mutants in the domesticate
lignin now extends all the way across
the obsession zone so it just doesn't
doesn't have that breakpoint
so that suggests them that a functional
position zone requires a narrow layer of
small cells and differential
magnification and this is sort of if you
look up obsession zone in the literature
this is sort of the description you will
get is that it's you've got to have
different lignin and then this narrow
layer of small cells defining the break
point so that suggested a fairly
straightforward set of experiments which
turned out to be really good for summer
undergraduate students I highly
recommend anatomy and histology if
you've got summer interns because they
get to look at something nobody else has
ever looked at before and make a
discovery and produce some pretty
interesting data so raychel Tavares who
was an undergrad intern now a grad
student at UMass looked at brocco
codeine and this is obsession we call
above the blooms so it's right here we
expected it was gonna be just like
growths
we're gonna we expected we'd have this
same rice type obsession zone in between
the flowers and above the glooms and so
raychel looked at bracket podium by
stacking on and what she discovered
indeed was this nice little line of
small cells right here it very clear um
but if you look at the staining this is
safranin oh so the pink means lignin
what you discover is that the the
pattern is exactly backwards of what I
just saw showed you in rice so here's
here's the rice lignin and then the
obsession zone itself is non Lena fide
and in bracket podium the obsessions out
itself is heavily lignified and not on
either side here's this other more
specific latent stain so that was
distressing but we thought oh well
there's still a nice little line of thin
walled cells so what about obsession
below the glooms what does that look
like well this was
studied by John Hodge who was a master
student in the lab he's now a PhD
candidate at Oklahoma State and John got
looking at the obsession zone in sight
areas seat area V artists which is
closely related to switchgrass and phony
oh and he's looking at this region right
at the bottom
the obsession zone is right here right
below such sectioning right through here
and I put this embryo over here this is
a mature grass embryo just to prove to
you that this spikelet really is mature
it's not that we got the sage wrong
there's basically no little line of
cells at all we've looked at enough of
these I put this dotted line on just to
show you where it breaks we've looked at
enough to know that's where it happens
but you're not seeing any clearly
differentiated abscission zone at all
and if you stain it with these like
safranin oh here's the lignin it's just
around the outside and I put bright
podium next to it just so you can see
the comparison there's the podium
position zone which remembers the
inverse of the rice and even if you
stain it with a gritty and orange
it's not just the stain there's the
lignin out here and there's lignin of
course in the vasculature but there is
it this thing breaks right here so there
is no cellular differentiation this is
stained with taffy which lets you know
where the nuclei are and points out live
cells the cells are live right through
there so nothing's dying um and I don't
want to spend too much time on this one
point but we we've done a number of
other approaches we still can't figure
out what it is that marks the obsession
zone in this particular species so just
to summarize the histology histological
comparisons of among these three species
in rice America podium yeah we've got
this canonical position zone where the
obsession zone cells are slightly
significantly smaller than the
surrounding cells seat area once you
know where to look
they are slightly smaller but not
compelling so differential ignition
definitely in rice and broccoli but not
sat area and the decision zone itself
not lignified in Rice's Terrier but not
recommended so we're not seeing a lot of
conservation so we then tried to rescue
that with another hypothesis and said
well maybe you know each one of these
things is in a different clade and at
least it's representative of the clade
so that everything was related to seat
area we'll have a seat area obsession
zone and bracket podium so forth and so
our undergraduate intern last summer was
Patricia Leyva
who decided to get serious about this
and we said fine just section everything
you can get hold of well it turned out
everything she can have to hold up and
she could get through in a short period
of time was an enormous amount so it's
all these species that are up here that
she's actually looked at and I'm not
gonna walk you through every single
species they're just all different you
know this one does this there's the
obsession zone it's not liquefied at all
either side and that's Brett Bodine
which you've already seen this is teff
over here and teff actually breaks right
there so yeah they're all different
and to figure out whether that track
with phylogeny she she simply if she
mapped all these characters on to a
pruned grass phylogeny and if you just
look at the position that's coded as
basically one is above the glooms and
two is below the glooms and that isn't
consistent with in any and doesn't match
the phylogeny in terms of having the
tiny little cells one is having small
cells and two is not having a set of
small cells that doesn't match in' and D
is the cell wall pattern so green means
not like a fine and pink means is the
color of the stain meaning lignin and
that doesn't track the phylogeny at all
so in terms of the question we're trying
to answer if we look at his knowledge II
the answer is no there is no
conservation in the structure or the
obsession zone so that was not great but
you start thinking well maybe there's
there's some underlying genetic
conservation even though there's even
there there's no histological
transposition and RNA see so let's look
at QTL studies and it certainly they've
been a lot of them particularly in rice
as i mentioned they've identified
several genes that control the obsession
zone and a few years ago our colleague
Andrew gauss wrote a review paper in the
american journal of botany where took
the rice chromosomes and put on them
just the location of the QTL from all
the published studies up to that point
QTL are here in these black boxes and
you know they the genes are listed under
here it will not be mentioning too many
of the gene names today but you know
they've been well localized and some of
the genes in the cloned and the question
is in
what does it look like when you put
other species on here so red is is Xia
and green is sorghum brown a seat area
and what you see just by looking at how
the colors line up is in fact there's
not much overlap expect in this one
region here so a lot of stuff that seems
to be unique to rice a lot of stuff
that's unique to the other species
possibly some similarity and that region
of similarity seems to all cover this
one
gabi transcription factor which is known
as shattering one which was originally
identified in a sort of cross as shown
here so I be mentioning focusing on this
is one if you can hang on to this name
the yabby genes shattering one that is
shared across a lot of different species
in these QTL studies so that raises a
question about natural variation
remember I started out by saying our
ancestors who domesticated all the
cereals we're selecting unconsciously
from standing variation in wild clans
and if that was gonna work I mean we
know it did work there have to be non
shattering mutations that are relatively
common in that in wild populations if
there aren't it if the mutations aren't
bigger than it doesn't matter how much
you select on I mean you don't get
anywhere with it but nobody's actually
surveyed a very larger set of a wild
germ plasm for reduced shattering and
then gone on to clone a gene so I'm
going to tell you about doing that now
because we've did that and the the clamp
that we looked at was green millet which
is Citterio be reduced and it's shown
here growing in its natural habitat in
the United States which is right next
door
wait you can see the tarmac over there
it's a very Reedy plant and we collected
it pretty widely throughout the US and
got hold of some material outside of the
US it's a small diploid plant it's been
being used as a model for a number of
things particularly for studies in c4
photosynthesis because it's small its
diploid its rapid cycling it can be
transformed so so quite a few labs are
using that using this as as a model and
then quite recently we've been involved
we I should say is actually folks at JDI
so this group led by Germans have
produced a new assembly of a reference
line so there was an old version and
this is a an updated much much better
version line known as a ten-time a
mentioned during this talk a bit I'll
try not to this so it's a really nice
assembly
it's basically all nine chromosomes and
relatively small number of contacts with
a real good and 50 so we have this
really lovely assembly and as part of
that project we also collected and see
598 diverse lines from particularly from
the US and Canada as well as elsewhere
and I'm putting this map up here for a
couple of reasons one is when you're
working on national diversity in most
cases you don't have a gene bank to go
to if you want to you go get it
so that's what we did the yellow dots
are trips that well I did that one
people from my lab made over a period of
several years max Feldman from Ivan
Baxter just loved blue loops and then
green and red was from Huang this
macfoster shouldn't show something else
and that is of course that st. Louis is
the center of the universe sorry
and also that seat area emeritus is very
way Tweety and grows really well along
interstate highways one one of the
people from formerly from my lab I do
need to give a shout out to is a guy
named Matt estep who's now at
Appalachian State and he did the
collecting all the way up to here and
there is another one of the reference
lines that I'll probably mention at
least once called Hemi Oh 34 that is
very widely used now in the Emmy stands
for Mattie step so that's so his his
line is becoming very widely used and so
the jdi's sequenced sequence libraries
for each of these things covered to very
high coverage each one has been
assembled to know them and I've got a
lot of snips did a lot of
presence/absence variation 98% of the
genes are shared among all the species
and there's done a bunch of Adam Healy
and sue John my meaty at the jgi
HudsonAlpha have done a lot of
population genetics on this which I'm
only just gonna mention more and passing
for this talk but there's a lot there
population genetic analysis shows four
major introductions from the old world
so there's a stuff in pink
we're calling the central population and
that is genetically very similar to
material from China the blue is very
similar to things from southern Europe
and Turkey sort of Caucasus green
there's the northern population which
also extends across Eurasia and then
there's the orange in the west coast
population which is also parts of the
Western Asia so a lot of introductions
from the old world and who Wang was not
BASF phenotype this sub
these lines about 200 of them and assess
them for shattering so there's here's a
bunch of plants over here and you can
see there's a big pile of seeds
spikelets that are falling off obviously
very high shattering pile of pilot
plants and from that he did a
genome-wide Association analysis which
identified a single peak right here
covering a pretty large QTL but it
didn't cover any previously known and
shattering locusts so none of the stuff
from rice what he did find was he
managed by various combinations of tests
as a causal gene which we're calling
less shattering one just because the
reduces shattering it doesn't completely
abolish it it's an uncharacterized nib
so there's a harsh shattering line which
happens to be like ma 34 and there's a
low shattering line which is the
reference in which there's a mutation
that causes a non-conservative amino
acid substitution so to validate that
this was not done with CRISPR so here's
the wild-type allele over here
fre shattering and then the CRISPR line
is substantially less shattering you
know once again it's not a complete
abolishment of shattering but it's a lot
less and we validated that by measuring
the strength of the obsession zone which
is that's a technique that's used
frequently in this approach where you
take the inflorescence and hang it
upside down on the force gauge and then
grab one spike with a pair of tweezers
and pull
and the force required braking force
required for the position zone turns up
on the force gauge this is a very boring
experiment but it gives you pretty good
data which is shown here so here's the
tensile strength of the obsession zone
the high shattering wild-type this is
any 34 shown in red and you can see
after did about 18 days after heading
it's dropped close to zero the slightly
lower shattering while the wheel does
shatter but later and then the crisper
lung the tensile strength stays very
high so change over development
validated that and then we also found
that the domesticated version of green
millet which is Fausto Mullins so this
is the wild one this is the domestic it
actually has a transposon in less form
that appears to disable it so it seems
to be a gene that has contributed to
domestication obviously can't be the
whole story because it's not a complete
non shattering phenotype so then let's
just then go back to some QTL studies
that have been done by colleagues and
have also published and question is does
it fall under any known uto for
shattering that is is a domestication
gene so here's a QTL map of shattering
from an RI line that was made in Andrew
dowsed made and has developed in his lab
between a wild deteriorate as' and the
cultivated foxtail millet sh-1 which I
mentioned to you earlier the one that
comes up in all the other QTL studies is
we're right and the question is just
less one follow fall under this
chromosome five and no it doesn't that's
not less one less one is actually over
here so what we're thinking our thinking
right now is that the transposon unless
one probably reduced shattering and they
have
in early involved in early domestication
but then subsequent much stronger
mutations were involved in actually
producing this completely non chattering
domestic so just to summarize the seat
area genome-wide Association studies
we've got a high quality genome a lot of
wild diversity a lot of good population
genetics and then use G wast from that
to I find a novel domestication locus
which was validated with CRISPR and
obviously pretty produces a resource for
other exploring other traits
what this does is it adds a species
specific gene to the list of genes from
other species and other QTL studies so
just talk about less one and these other
ones again I'm not going to go through
them in detail but what you'll see is
that they're each one this is a rice
flan this seems to be specifically rice
this is rice these guys are true kisi
ate only that's wheat and barley and
only sh-1 seems to be in multiple
species so what we're seeing is then is
that from these cutie on and gos studies
the controls of obsession appear to vary
among species however this kind of work
is not designed to get you the whole
network and so it's quite possible that
there is indeed if conserved Network
that's moved around the plant which is
where we started first but we've just
found a whole lot of different ways to
break it and you know so we say it's
less one involved in chattering and
other species and and we'll come back to
that but don't is from based on getting
back to our original original question
from the question of the histology
there's no conservation from QT OMG was
inconclusive
maybe shattering one so obviously what's
the thing to do things to RNA seek and
so this was a collaboration led by in
Chengdu in my lab and with Hao who an
eiderdown oklahoma state and remember
that we have rice breaking above the
glooms bracket podium between the
flowers and seat area
the obsession zone below the glooms so
what you interesting did was dissected
out the region of the obsession zone for
each of those three species so you've
seen all these so far so here's the
obsession zone
second out the regions roughly with this
orange box and then as a sort of
internal troll she looked at the area
right below the lower region and the
area right above that is the upper
region and so could look compare the
genes that were expressed in the
exertion zone to the ones above and
below and this Venn diagram simply shows
that the set of one to one orthologues
is largely the same
I'm almost be she's so that because the
seven genes that are expressed in that
region is shared so then the question is
alright which one's of those are
specifically restricted to the obsession
zone and she did it a bunch of different
analyses inching and how a lot this I'm
just showing you the results of WGC na
and just to walk you through this this
diagram here what we have is a heat map
of expression levels these have three
replicates for below the glooms three
replicates within the obsession zone and
three replicates above the obsession
zone this is at the young developmental
stage and then the same set of
replicates below the obsession zone and
above the obsession zone had an old
developmental stage and for this
particular cluster in rice there are
about 3,000 genes that are clearly
distinguishing the young stage from the
old stage they're up at the young stage
they're down at the old stage and each
species has modules that look like that
and they overlap significantly so
there's the 3,000 ones I just showed you
in rice there are about 2200 in bracket
podium and the overlap among those is
about 850 genes that are differentially
expressed shared between them highly
significant overlap suggesting there's a
lot of similarity in terms of the
developmental stages but of course what
we want to know is what's happening with
the obsession zone itself so here's a
rice set the genes that are highly
expressed in the obsession zone at the
young developmental stage how much
higher any obsession zone then either
below or above and again every species
has a couple of positions done specific
knowledge about particular developmental
stages so the question then the imaging
and how asked was toward what's shared
among these that here's where I guess
there's a set of 962 here's bracket
podium there's 100
what is shared between those modules and
the answer is basically nothing there's
a little bit of overlap which is barely
statistically significant given the
number of comparisons very low numbers
and of course what we really want is
this three-way overlap and there are
three genes so there's a mid there's a
lysine decarboxylase about which we know
nothing and Akuma rate ligase which is
presumably involved in lignin formation
so our first thought was well maybe we
just messed up the analysis maybe we
should be considering analyzing things
slightly differently in terms of which
genes we included in how we did the
comparison we did they're completely
different analysis and we got exactly
the same result in fact the second
analysis we only got two things
overlapping although they were two of
the same ones we saw in the first one so
here's the mid highly expressed in the
obsession zone at a young stage and the
lysine Dyer decarboxylase also among all
three species
there's the expression domain of this
myth is in the obsession zone so that's
good in two of the species couldn't pick
it up in seat area which either means
that the RNA seek is misleading or this
method in situ is is not sensitive
enough you might be thinking about what
happened to less one and the answer is
it wasn't in this analysis at all
because it was not differentially
expressed in anything not in seat area
beer it is very low level of expression
in rice and not expressed at all in
bracket odium
so again it's not only species-specific
whatever it's doing is probably not
specific to the obsession zone and the
effect on shattering may be a byproduct
of something else
if we go back to the known genes the
genes that have been known in rice
there's these are ones that have been
identified in the literature and their
obsessions own specific and rice but if
you look at those same genes in the
obsession modules as to where they fall
in the other species like this again
they're not always even in an obsession
module in the other species thinking
that perhaps we needed to look earlier
in development it's entering did a lot
of in situ hybridization at earlier
stages says all this stage of in situ
hybridization was the youngest stage
from the RNA see you can see very
clearly gene expression this happens to
be a petal of two and you can see it at
the earlier stage so this is rice again
this is confirming and published data
and then if we look at the other two
species there's no expression there let
me put them that's where the obsession
zone is and what you can see is that
they're really just it's not simply not
expressed in the obsession zone and the
other species
same thing for other things so if we get
back then to the question that we
started with is the obsessions aren't
conserved by a developmental controlled
by conserve developmental module
the answer is histologically no the QT l
is inconclusive may EBS h1 and RNA seek
points to only two genes
um looking at sh1 it's muted a
desiccated cereals we don't know as with
everything else we don't know what any
of these things do here's SH one insight
ooze but the gene networks differ among
species so although maybe a conserved
component of the network its specific
role may be different between species
so the overall answer the question is no
the set of genes involved in a
prostitution zone is largely shared but
how they are deployed is mostly
different the practical implications of
this are mean that for improving the
orphan crops remember I talked about
Antonio right at the beginning or novel
crops things like no perennial wheat
grass for any of that improvement cannot
proceed without reducing shattering if
these networks are species specific we
need to study each crop individually as
to how it actually is put together sh1
mid 26 may be exceptions and we're
certainly pursuing looking at those to
see how they are deployed particularly
in tough Antonio and the other thing
that we're pursuing is exactly how they
work because at the cell level is not
known in general we're thinking that
most the genes that are necessary for a
position are probably establishing
development of the spikelet and a
pedestal rather than controlling
obsession per se that is if you affect
spikelet development or pedicel
development it's going to have an effect
on the obsessions own sort of indirectly
and the obsessions on itself may be
controlled by only a handful of genes or
may be deployed only at the very last
minute before obsession or it may not be
transcriptionally regulated so with that
I'm gonna stop and thank the team
particularly at HudsonAlpha
the people who did a lot of the work on
the seat area genome and all the
diversity work and the GOS studies great
bunch of people who work with and then
this is my lab at the Danforth Plant
Science Center most everything most of
what I talked about today was work
inching you and yes that is the Stanley
so um like to thank you for all your
attention and thanks again to the
organizers for putting together a great
symposium
thank you so much Toby that was a really
interesting talk and I see you already
have a few questions in the chat it
looks like the first one was from Hannah
Jeffery you want to unmute yourself and
ask that one yes thank you I was
interested in that map that you had
shown earlier and I realize literally
basic question from some perspectives
but I was thinking about it in terms of
ecology
well I think Hannah just disappeared
I'm fine okay it's very loud very I'm I
was thinking about it from an ecological
point of view and I was wondering do you
think that maybe you could find more
homologs to important genes near the
Illinois area where a lot of the species
seem to radiate out from looked at the
whole array because there's there's not
only been a lot of introduction a lot of
the introductions seem to that would be
an interesting place to look at more
closely specifically look at the the
admix lines in particular well that
isn't that is variant that is very cool
to to see that perhaps there would be
something unique that would have popped
up later on as opposed to a closer to
the epicenter so the one thing is the to
kinda be the epicenter is hardly driven
by by the introduction history of this
thing we don't have a real good picture
of the diversification across Eurasia
the sapling is just super sparks there
and I think your question probably would
be would be really interesting to
address closer to where that is actually
meeting and that we actually seeing
better signature ecological interactions
yeah it's a really good question I agree
thank you thanks huh
no problem looks like we have another
question from Ln he's a bit
hi hi do you plan to automate your
tensile experiments in the future
because that's really cool work but
someone pulling it by hand may affect
the quality of results yes it also
affects the enthusiasm of the person
doing the pulling it's yeah it's not a
great experiment we've tried to we've
tried other assays we have other ways of
estimating kind of how many seeds fall
off you're counting seeds or weighing
them and that sort of thing the tensile
strength is very nice and and
quantitative and yeah if we had a way to
do that more easily it certainly would
be would be good but I haven't been able
to come up with the challenging part is
simply getting old and spiked work and
you know if there was a way to grab it
in some some good way it would be it
would be great so yeah if you have any
ideas okay thank you
Thanks and then it looks like there's a
question from stephen maryk
oh yes I was wondering about if you
looked at any of the micro rna's or
small RNAs in the abscission zone region
and they have any homology to the Navy
they identified differentially expressed
genes yeah sorry what were their utrs
so that's a really good question and
it's something we've sought them out and
just haven't made the libraries to do
the sequencing but it's as we're going
forward we are almost certainly going to
be doing that a little of two genes
which do come up and some of these
species are regulated by micro rna's so
yeah I guess the answer to your question
is no we haven't done it but yes we'd
love to and we'll be Thanks yeah
and we also have a question from Jim
Holland oh hi hi Toby that was a great
talk
um I was wondering about looking at
general where there's variation within
the genus for where the shattering
occurs and my recollection was in a
novena that different species will
shatter at different places in the
floral structure so I'm wondering if
looked at cases like that we have not
certainly with vena that you're right
there's different you know different
cultivated lines and different species
do break up in different ways and that's
also true with the the weak relative
wheat and barley relatives they you know
they just break in different places I
think we had gone into this assuming
there was just going to be a comp
completely conserved network and so we
hadn't really dug into the the within
species diversity but given what we know
now that might be might definitely be
worth pursuing
Jeff Doyle you want to go ahead and ask
your question
yeah
Toby nice talk is is cell death involved
an incision
you know the literature is ambiguous and
if it isn't involved it's pretty late
some people some species in litchi where
obsession of one cell layer from another
involves cell death but in in the cereal
crops the assumption which i think
hasn't been very well tested the
assumption is that it's an active
process that is the cells right there
the obsessions ona actually secrete
cellulases and pectin aces out dissolves
a cell wall and they can't obviously do
that if it unless they're alive so it
may not you know so that may not be
involved the exception may be intense is
the place where tough breaks it actually
looks like those cells just fall apart
becomes necrotic or something so yeah I
guess the answer to your question is we
don't know yeah I was just thinking that
maybe that would be something a process
that would be you know sort of difficult
to detect by any of the histological
methods or RNA seek but could account
for some program in there that would
actually cause a group of cells to die
and and create that that breakpoint yeah
yeah in it and then that may actually be
a good possibility and one of the
challenges of this is once you start
focusing on things like the actual
breaking process itself it's hard to
study because the things break things
just fall apart on you as you're trying
to work with them but yeah no I think
that's a really really good possibility
Thanks
and we have also a question from Chelsea
Specht yeah Toby thank you that was a
fantastic talk I just I was also
thinking like Jeff about about program
cell death and also going back in my
head as what are the processes to study
that I know a lot of it was with
nectaries where things start to degrade
and then you get the secretion but with
a abscission zone it's different in that
you don't get that cellular secretion
along with the death you actually get I
don't know you were just saying the
cells kind of break apart or just or
they lose their cell walls right they
they kind of dry up I guess I like a
better word but I was thinking about the
signaling if there's any way that to
detect some kind of I don't know if it
would be signaling or hormone or some
sort of small molecule that might be
involved with setting up a particular
zone where the cells then are no longer
involved in growth but rather somehow
are are enzymatically broken apart yeah
I mean I think there's there's got to be
something like that we're currently
focusing on a couple of things on in
because we actually have a crisp
community for sh-1 I think that you can
compare between wild-type and mutant
we're focusing on Solal structure so
like the distribution and possible
breakdown of very the various
carbohydrates the pectin xilu cans and
also there seems to be a hormonal
response involved so yeah I'm just kind
of watch this space I don't know the
data are too preliminary to talk about
but but yes I think you're the situation
just outlined to be may well be what's
going on well it's it's really
interesting and I really appreciate your
doing your real rigor and efforts and
looking across all these grasses and
finding that every time you look at it
it's different it's different and and
well that's it that's all that's
challenging it's also incredibly
exciting to think about all the ways
that that crosses have come to the same
to the same conclusion but doing it
differently to affect thinking about
ecologically what differences that might
make or what these responses to be and
what adaptation these plans might be
using this differential response to
evolve towards this is really
interesting as well yeah from an
evolutionary point of view it actually
makes no sense because all of these
things have obsession zones they're all
think you know I mean if you use a
strictly sort of phylogenetic definition
of homology they're you know they're
homologous in the sense that they all go
back you know everybody has an obsession
zone so perfectly when one move it yeah
but but that's where it is thank you
thanks Joseph
looks like Jeff you have another
question yes yes thanks yeah just
occurred to me you know when you were
showing all those really nice
histological pictures about how variable
different species were it makes me
wonder do you see that same lot of that
same variation perhaps within a species
did your student look within a species
to see how variable that was at that
level no we haven't met that sort of
follows you know Jim Holmes suggestion
is is there are species that do bury and
we just haven't drilled down to that
that level of variation but but yeah I
mean I think that starts to be you know
it wouldn't have occurred to me that
genetically or histologically there
would be variation within a species for
obsession you know we know the position
of it can change but now that we're
finding this amount of diversity
absolutely I think that would be one one
way to go would be to look within a
species yeah I was I wasn't thinking so
much of position as Jim question but
actually significant and you know like
all of the whole suite of characters
that the different types that you return
to essentially yeah that's actually
something variable yeah no that's that's
a good question and and we don't know we
don't have the data all right thanks
yeah
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu